We will start analyzing spectra by first
looking at an unrealistic ideal spectra,
and then we'll move to real spectra.
Let's start from analyzing
this short peptide.
Let's generate all its prefix peptides and
all its suffix peptide.
Let's measure the masses of all prefix
peptides and all suffix peptides, and
our goal is, from these masses, to
reconstruct the original peptide.
Can we do this?
Well, an important thing to realize
is that we don't know which masses
correspond to prefix fragments and which
masses correspond to suffix fragments, and
therefore, what we are given is
the ideal spectrum of the peptide,
which is simply a collection of
both prefix and suffix masses.
We will say that a given
peptide "explains" a spectrum
if the ideal spectrum of this
peptide is equal to the spectrum.
So we have now a decoding problem,
which is to reconstruct
a peptide from its ideal spectrum.
Input: A collection of integers, Spectrum.
Output: An amino acid string
Peptide that explains Spectrum.
To solve it, let's construct a graph.
We will form a set of nodes of this
graph by designing a single node for
every element of the spectrum,
and we will construct edges of the graph
by connecting two nodes if the difference
between their corresponding labels
is equal to the mass of amino acids,
and we will label this edge by
the mass of this amino acid.
Here's the graph we construct for
our ideal spectrum, and
what will be the solution of our problem
of decoding an ideal spectrum problem?
Of course, we need to walk from
the source node 0 to the sink, and
the path that we'll spell will correspond
to the peptide we are trying to find.
As a result, I propose the following
Decoding Ideal Spectrum Algorithm:
First, construct a graph from Spectrum.
Second, find a path from source
to sink in the resulting graph.
And finally, return the amino acid
string spelled by this path.
That sounds simple, but
does it really work for all spectra?
It clearly worked for the
simple spectrum that we considered before.
Let's take a look at this spectrum,
and I will tell you that this is an ideal
spectrum of an unknown peptide.
Let's construct the graph of Spectrum and
let's consider this path in this graph.
This graph spells out the peptide NTTAG.
But if we take the ideal
spectrum of NTTAG,
it will turn out that it is not
equal to the original spectrum,
which means that we
are doing something wrong.
Of course, in this graph, there is
a path that spells the correct
solution of the problem, but
we don't know how to find it.
What we can do, however, is to consider
all possible paths in the graph, and
this is done by a new version of
the Decoding Ideal Spectrum Algorithm,
that first constructs the graph of Spectrum,
explores all paths in the resulting graph,
but for each path,
it first checks the condition,
if the ideal spectrum of the peptide
is really equal to the spectrum.
If this condition is met,
then it returns the peptide.
So this is definitely a correct
solution of the problem,
but is it an efficient solution?
You will see it that it's actually
an exponential algorithm, but
there are polynomial solutions for this problem
that we will not cover in this course.
Our goal, however,
is to move from decoding ideal
spectra to the decoding real spectra.
And on this line you see an ideal
spectrum will be some false and
missing masses and the real spectrum.
And the reality is that, in spectra generated
by mass spectrometers, there are usually
many false and missing masses,
thus complicating our problem of
decoding a real spectrum,
that we will consider in the next lecture.
An important thing about decoding a real
spectrum is that its objective is to
find an amino acid string Peptide
that explains Spectrum the best.
But what does it mean to be the "best"
peptide explaining the spectrum?
We will learn about this
in the next segment.